c'est avec hélène frade on a la une de
la presse les réactions occidentales à
la reconnaissance par la russie de
l'indépendance des territoires
séparatistes de l'est de l'ukraine une
décision qui a été accueillie comme une
déclaration de guerre après des semaines
d'activités diplomatiques et freiner les
quotidiens occidentaux à l'image du
quotidien français libération font face
à cette réalité l'ukraine est désormais
face à la guerre l'ukraine face à la
guerre est la seule question aujourd'hui
serait de savoir jusqu'où vladimir
poutine a l'intention d'aller pour le
président américain cité par le
quotidien belge le soir les manoeuvres
aux russes marquent le début d'une
invasion d'une guerre pour laquelle des
causes et des tranchées ont déjà été
creusés alors qu'on ignore quelle sera
la prochaine étape si le kremlin va
annexer les territoires séparatistes
il y aura des combats avec l'armée
ukrainienne des bombardements et des
morts par milliers et aux etats-unis le
washington post appellent l'ex
l'occident à soutenir les patriotes
ukrainien le quotidien américain cite
feu le sénateur john mccain lors de
l'invasion russe de la crimée en 2014 le
combat de l'ukraine est aussi le nôtre
nous sommes tous des ukrainiens
l'ukraine et les spectres du passé face
à poutine sommes nous tous des
ukrainiens en suisse le journal le temps
s'interroge sur la réaction du coc
occidental elle a une voix le dessin de
chappatte montre des soldats de la
guerre de 14 18 dans ces tranchées
ukrainienne qu'on a aperçu à l'instant
ces tranchées d'aujourd'hui tu vois
venir quelque chose demande un poilu le
passé répond le soldat ukrainien le
quotidien rappelle lui que la solidarité
dans la vraie vie comme dans les
rapports de force entre états n'est
jamais mesurée par des mots mais par des
actes et que dans le cas de l'ukraine
cette solidarité ne sera jamais à un
niveau susceptible de faire reculer
poutine le journal propose plutôt aux
européens de faire ce simple aveu en
forme d'épitaphe désolé nous ne sommes
pas tous d ukraine mais en fatalisme
mêlée d'indignation notamment du côté la
presse britannique un fidèle elle même
la presse tabloïd rivalisent de
superlatifs et de jeux de mots pour
vilipender vladimir poutine stop mad
vlad arrêté vlad le fou titre ce matin
dasson tandis que le daily mirror
tempête contre la faiblesse des
sanctions annoncées contre la russie en
demandant au gouvernement britannique de
sortir tout de suite l'argent sale de la
russie du royaume-uni
la palme du bon goût de pauline revient
indubitablement au gratuit métro qui
promet d'attraper poutine par les
roubles c'est parce est une part les
roubignoles alors ça là on va en parler
maintenant c'est beaucoup de colère
également en allemagne où le
gouvernement a annoncé la suspension du
gazoduc nord stream 2 en représailles à
l'annonce du kremlin le poutine nous
attaquent aussi titre en effet le très
populaire bild qui se demandent je cite
si les allemands n'ont pas été trop
gentil avec poutine ou trop rare le
chancelier ou la seule sur le set tout
comme son homologue français d'ailleurs
cédé mener jusqu'au bout pour tenter de
trouver une issue diplomatique à cette
crise la déception est d'autant plus
vive et la remise en question brutale
une fois de plus poutine a trompé
l'occident constate avec amertume le
frankfurter allgemeine zeitung qui
estime que le président russe a déchiré
ce qui constituait jusque-là le
soubassement de la politique étrangère
de berlin vis-à-vis de moscou l'idée
qu'à force de patience à force de
compréhension je cite il était possible
de parvenir à un accord avec la russie
et aux états unis joe biden a également
haussé le ton et il a annoncé de
nouvelles sanctions contre la russie de
washington post genre parle d'une
réponse calibré face au cataclysme qui
menacent l'ukraine des sanctions
limitées pour le moment mais qui
pourront se transformer en sanction
sévère et paralysante si les blindés les
troupes russes se déplace au delà de la
ligne de contact dans la région du
dombass et plus loin en ukraine auquel
cas les états unis et leurs alliés
seraient prêts d'après le washington
post a imposé un isolement économique
strictes à la russie et quelle réaction
précisément ici le journal izvestia qui
est proche du kremlin assure que les
sanctions occidentales bien que 106 ne
constitue pas une menace pour l'économie
russe le site nationaliste svoboda et
après ça se moque lui ouvertement pour
sa part de l'otan dont il met en doute
la puissance des dirigeants occidentaux
présentent et je cite comme des
imbéciles et en particulier du vieux
président américain tous accusés de
rêver d'une intervention de l'otan dans
le donbass sans toutefois vouloir se
battre pour le régime de kiev le journal
d'opposition novaïa gazeta dont le
rédacteur en chef hans a été récompensé
du prix nobel de la paix l'année
dernière prévient pour sa part que les
objectifs réels de vladimir poutine ne
se content atteint que par le
démembrement complet de l'ukraine la
reconnaissance des séparatistes est une
étape pas un but soutient le journal qui
affirme que le président poutine n'est
pas le seul d'ailleurs à faire dans le
révisionnisme historique et comme moi
deux autres dirigeants mondiaux le
président chinois xi jinping et le
président turc recep tayyip erdogan et
bien profiteront volontiers de
l'effondrement de l'ordre mondial pour
construire leur propre empire sur ces
décombres que tous les deux sont trop
intelligents pour briser cet ordre eux
mêmes mais qu'ils seront heureux de voir
comment le kremlin joue le rôle de
brise-glace merci haleine pour cette
rude presse et vous vers retrouver
d'ailleurs cette revue de presse en
podcast sur toute notre plateforme